recently the medical ethicist Zeke
Emanuel published a provocative article
in in the article he states that he
hopes he dies at age 75 he thinks people
are living too long and he says I hope I
die at 75 that's what Zeke Emanuel wrote
this article has a lot of people riled
up here now to respond to this
controversy is our good friend Larry
King
[Applause]
I'm down Thank You Conan I'm here and
I'm ticked as soon as I read that
article I thought here we go again
this stupid argument comes up every 200
years this means this is my 10th time
addressing it
[Applause]
first of all why 75 75 was my favorite
year I don't mean 75 years old I mean
the Year 75 you know I've been in
people's death pools since before you
were born Conan can you believe some
people pick me over Julius Caesar living
past 75 is great there's plenty to do
I'm constantly calling up the Discovery
Channel saying hey that's not how
dinosaurs walked being older means
you've seen a lot for example I watched
the Big Bang before it was a television
show by the way Zeke I knew the guy you
were named after the prophet Ezekiel now
he was an [ __ ] too if I was past my
prime would I be able to do this watch
[Applause]
Hey
don't forget to watch Larry King now on
aura TV and Hulu streaming now and for
the next 600 years
[Applause]
he became a Borscht Belt comic oh it's
great
singing I'm tektites I am
[Laughter]
you